what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and
in this video we're going to be talking
about the most ancient and overpowered
clan
in naruto that's made up of horned
aliens as weird as that sounds
of course i'm referring to the osutuki
clan and i'm making this video because
we got over 4 000 likes on the uzumaki
clan video
in fact we have over 15 000 likes as i
write the script which is
insane you guys blew me away with your
response on that one
similar deal here turn that like button
blue share this video with your cultured
naruto friends
and when we hit over 5 000 blue thumbs
on this video
i'll get started the next naruto video
asap leave suggestions for what topics
you want me to cover next in the
comments
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future naruto
videos and you won't be able to comment
on how you clicked faster than minato
and that would be a huge tragedy
no one wants that so click that bell and
while you wait for the next video to
drop you can check out my growing naruto
playlist where you'll find videos about
the hokage do chiha dozumaki and more
link in the description now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all
let's look at a brief overview slash
history of the clan
so we can clear up some confusion before
we get into specific members
as i mentioned yototsuki are not humans
but rather aliens and a motto
further defines them as parasites we
actually have the otsutsuki clan to
thank for shinobi
and ninjutsu on earth the clan members
traveled through dimensions they would
plant tentail saplings which would
become god trees
across universes and dimensions so they
could harvest their fruit
the god tree's roots spread across a
planet and absorb energy from it
including from its inhabitants in
general the planet would die in the
process
and the god tree would grow a large
chakra fruit which could grant the
otsutsuki god-like power and longevity
then the yotutsuki clan members would
move on to other worlds
and dimensions searching for another god
tree and another
chakra fruit according to a motto
otutsuki clan members kaguya and ishiki
came to earth long ago with the usual
objective of planting the god tree and
harvesting its chakra fruit
but kaguya had a change of plants and
turned against ishiki
kaguya against the wishes of ishiki and
the rest of her clan
consumed the earth's chakra fruit by
herself and gained godlike power
she used infinite tsukuyomi to stop war
between humans and to bring about peace
temporarily
she turned the imprisoned infinite
tsukuyomi victims into a white zetsu
army that could help her fight back
against any angered clansmen
who would now want to punish kaguya and
take away her chakra
in the eyes of dotsuki clan at large
kaguya was a traitor
kaguya eventually gave birth to two sons
hagoromo
aka this age of six paths aka the
ancestor of shinobi
and hamura the ancestor of the hugo clan
who ended up pissing out to the moon
these two were the first people born
with the ability to wield chakra but
kaguya was not happy because she wanted
all the chakra so she turned against her
sons
she combined with the earth's god tree
and became the ten tails hagoromo and
hamura ended up defeating the tan tails
with their sealing jutsu six paths
chibaku tensei and created the moon in
the process
so the husk of the ten tails was trapped
inside the newly formed moon
while the juicy chakra of the ten tails
was sealed into hagoromo
making him the first jinchuriki hagoromo
gave birth to two sons
indra and asura otutsuki sometimes
called ashura otsutsuki depending on the
translation do chiha clan would come
from indra's bloodline while the uzumaki
and sandro clan
would come from asura's bloodline and as
we know their descendants like them
would be born with the ability to use
chakra and ninjututsu
indra tutsuki is actually credited with
being the creator of ninjutsu before he
died hagoromo split the chakra of the
ten tails into nine-tailed beasts
so that it would be even more difficult
for the ten tails and thus kaguya to be
reborn
so in short aliens invaded the earth and
as a result humans gain ninja super
powers
now let's move on to the specific known
members of the clan
let's start off with osutuki number one
the ototuki betray her herself
princess kaguya otutuki the former
matriarch of the otsutuki clan
as i mentioned she was partners with
ishiki before she betrayed him
took the earth's chakra fruit for
herself and became the first
wielder of chakra on earth she's also
been referred to
as the progenitor of chakra and the
mother of chakra because she
accidentally passed on chocolate her two
sons
hagoromo and hamura otsutsuki and their
descendants
as i mentioned she tried to take the
chakra back by fusing with the god tree
and becoming the ten tails but failed
in the anime kaguya possessed
significant abilities even before she
ate the earth's chakra fruit
obviously she could travel across
universes and dimensions and she had the
genjutsu like abilities of hypnotizing
people
putting them to sleep and even erasing
their memories offensively
she could unleash a shockwave from her
eyes that could kill people
when kaguya ate the chakra fruit and
gained god-like power
she subdued the constantly warring land
she was believed to be a goddess by some
and a demon by others
she was so strong that hagoromo
represented as a godlike figure himself
and hamura
had to work together in battle with her
for months until they finally defeated
her only for her to return again in
naruto's time
that gives you a sense of just how
strong and resilient princess kaguya was
like most otsutsuki clan members kaguya
can levitate slash
fly and she can even read people's minds
in the anime
during the fight against naruto and
sasuke she could as sakura pointed out
rewrite the world of her dimensions in
an instant allowing her to create a
world of ice in the process and freeze
naruto and sasuke in place
as can be expected from the mother of
chakra her chakra reserves are off the
charts
while surpassing that of ten tails
jinchuriki madara on top of that kaguya
can absorb jutsu which unfortunately
makes the extremely cool informally op
jutsu amaterasu
useless by touching naruto and sasuke
she can at least temporarily prevent
them from moving while absorbing their
chakra
she can use the famous genjutsu infinite
tsukuyomi which can potentially trap
everyone in the world in an illusion
while kaguya siphons off their chakra
kaguya claims that she's immortal and
there's something to this since she can
regenerate quickly and regrow lost limbs
so it makes sense that the characters
have to actually seal her away
in order to defeat her understandably
the mother of chakra has great mastery
over chakra and can use
all five nature transformations and yin
and yang release
she can use her long hair as a weapon in
battle or even create
life that will be the physical
manifestation of her will like black
tsetsu notably kaguya can use her all
killing ash bones technique
to launch her bones and opponents they
can simply protrude from her body or she
can launch them as projectiles
upon contact living things will
disintegrate into ash making this an
exceptionally deadly technique
kaguya can also use the hella op more
expansive truth seeking ball
unlike normal truth-seeking orbs which
can't be regenerated once destroyed this
one can be created by kaguya
it has the power to reshape the world by
obliterating it first
kaguya also has the byakugan which got
passed down to hamura
and the renee sharingan as a third eye
on her forehead which is the predecessor
of both the shotgun and the renagan
which got passed down through hagoromo
the byakugan lets her see people's
chakra pathway system
and to recognize that naruto and sasuke
are reincarnations of asura and indra it
also gives her almost 360 degree
x-ray vision and notably her byakugan is
supposed to be far more powerful than
hamuras
among other things the renaissance lets
her cast
and recognize genjutsu use infinite
tsukuyomi and teleport herself
and others across space and dimensions
with this third eye kaguya can
manipulate the roots of the god tree and
turn people into white zetsu while she
gains incredible power from absorbing
their
chakra as mentioned kaguya can also
become the ten tails when fused with the
god tree
and now let's get to the second otusuki
on this list the sage of six paths
hagoromo otutsuki himself hagoromo has
been called the sage of six paths the
god of shinobi
the savior of the world and the god sage
of six packs
titles don't get much more fancy than
those he also holds the title being the
very first jinchuriki
of the ten tales no less in the original
naruto series hagoromo is considered to
be the strongest figure in history
aside from his mother kaguya whom he had
to team up with his brother to seal away
his own twin brother hamura admitted
that hagoromo
was the stronger of the two hagoromo is
so opie that even after his death he can
still observe the world talk to people
and even give them his chakra to make
them ridiculously stronger than they
were before
hagoromo had it all power and huge
chakra reserves
since he is the older fraternal twin he
is considered to be the first being born
with chakra he had an innate
understanding
and mastery over it so that he could use
chakra without hand seals
obviously his chakra reserves and power
got even more ridiculous when he became
the jinchuriki of the ten tales hagoromo
also had very impressive healing powers
that could seemingly heal anyone of
anything
in the anime he could create blades of
lightning or slice through things with
wind release
not only did he master yin and yang
release he could combine them to use the
creation of all things technique which
allowed him to create physical forms out
of nothingness
and then to breathe life into them this
is pretty much as godly as the technique
can get
and hagoromo used it to create the
nine-tailed beasts his sealing
techniques were amazing as we saw
he used ceiling to defeat kaguya to seal
the husk of the ten tails in the newly
formed moon
and to become the first ever ginchuriki
manga only fans might not know this but
in the anime
hagoromo developed a shotgun before the
renagon
it immediately had all three tomoe it
also eventually evolved into a mangekyo
shotgun that allowed him to summon a
complete body susano
that could deflect a tail beast bomb
from the ten tails
as far as we know he didn't have the
drawbacks usually associated with the
mangekyo shotgun like
deteriorating eyesight nagato a very
powerful character within the naruto
universe openly admitted that his power
was nothing compared to that
of hagoromos and of course he had the
renagon which he arguably mastered like
no other
this gave him access to all the six
paths techniques
which i discussed in my uzumaki video
with nagato
and in my uchiha video as well if you
want a more detailed breakdown on the
renagan you can check out those videos
hagoromo could also summon souls from
the pure land
which is the afterlife in naruto souls
can be reincarnated from the pure land
using impure world reincarnation
but not if they are sealed away in which
case their souls wouldn't be in the pure
land
hagoromo can also flex on a user of the
impure world reincarnation technique
by releasing souls from their vessels
and returning them to the pure land
in the anime the oldest and most revered
toad gama maru
aka the great toad sage taught hagoromo
senjutsu or
sage mode perhaps unsurprisingly at this
point hagoromo
excelled at senjutsu to the point where
gamamatu was shocked at how fast and
well this dude was picking it up
hagoromo developed his own unique and
advanced senjutu known as six path
sanjutsu which let him fly
flying is not anything crazy for an
otsutsuki but very cool nonetheless
and we know that hagaromo could grant
his six-pack sanjutsu to others
even after being long dead which is how
we got six-path sage mode naruto
hagoromo also has the all-nature
transformations
and yin slash yang release pack truth
seeking orbs
he can use true seeking orbs to create
other objects like a staff or the famous
sword of
nuno boko a double helix shaped sword
which obito claims can create the world
and destroyed as well
then there were the treasured tools of
the sage of six paths
which used so much chakra that they
could kill the average person if used
they were no problem for hagoromo though
who used them to generate any element
seal people into a gourd and more
and now we move on to otozuki number
three the eldest son of hagoromo and the
ancestor of the chiha clan
indra otutsuki madara and sasuke were
reincarnations of indra
indra was the older and at first much
more talented brother
he wanted to succeed his father but then
hagoromo
chose his younger brother asura to be
his successor
indra did not take this well and the two
brothers were pit against each other
destined to fight through their
reincarnations for generations to come
indra inherited hagoromo's eye powers
namely the shutting god he'd eventually
unlock the mangekyo shotting gun and
have access to a complete body susano he
had powerful chakra and precise chakra
control he excelled in taijutsu like
uchiha prodigies that would follow him
like hitachi for instance indra easily
outclassed his peers
indra expanded hagoromo's teaching of
ninshu into the fighting style we know
today as ninjutsu
thus indra and not hagoromo is credited
as the original creator of ninjutsu
unlike hagoromo indra couldn't just
freely manipulate chakra and so he had
to come up with hand seals to help him
out
these hand seals would become
foundational for all shinobi
he really was like the first ninja
creating the first clone technique along
with the first body replacement
technique
techniques that would become go-to moves
for the ninja of the future
indra even fashioned primitive kunai
hagoromo was amazed at indra's talent
and creativity and that means a lot
coming from the so-called god sage of
six packs
as far as nature transformations go
indra could use fire and lightning as
well as yin release
obviously this makes sense in sasuke his
reincarnation has always been heavily
associated with fire and lightning
release as well
indra would use lightning release to
augment his natural strength and speed
using it to easily penetrate through
flesh or to assist him with his body
flicker technique
indra could use his shotting gun to
paralyze a person with his gaze and as
mentioned eventually unlock the mangekyo
and thus the full body susanoo as well
in the anime indus mangekyo could also
use hino kagutsuchi
a technique that produced black flames
similar to matarasu
now let's move on to otsutsuki number
four asura the younger brother of indra
and the ancestor of both the senju and
uzumaki clans
like naruto who was asura's
reincarnation asura seemed untalented
early on
think about how naruto failed the
graduation exam three times
while it said that indra inherited his
father's eyes asura is said to have
inherited his body
and this meant that he was eventually
able to rival his brother's power
hagoromo preferred asura's philosophy
which was based on
love rather than on power and as a
result made him
his successor and blessed him with his
power this allowed asura to defeat indra
just like hashirama would go on to
defeat madara and naruto would go on to
defeat sasuke in their subsequent
reincarnations
like indra asura was skilled in taijutsu
but he also had a uniquely powerful life
force and great stamina
these traits would go on to be inherited
by his descendants for instance the
uzumaki clan are known for their
especially powerful life force and
that's what made it possible for naruto
and his mother to be nine tails
jinchuriki
in the anime asura was adept at sensing
chakra
healing people and could even launch his
own rasengan-esque
move called amenomihashira it's a very
interesting move where asura creates
five spiraling chakra orbs that look a
lot like rasangan's and encases them in
a larger orb when hit with another
attack the larger barrier orb will
absorb the blow
letting the other spheres continue the
chakra spheres will then explode on
contact
this move is not in the manga but if
these chakra spheres are anything like
that asengon then you can imagine the
chakra control required
to do something this crazy when it came
to nature transformations like naruto
asura excelled in wind release asura's
wind release could cut through rock or
protect him from enemy attacks
like a true airbender he also had access
to earth and water release baby known as
wood release the op release that the
first hokage was well known for
in the anime he could use the sage art
would release
true several hands technique just like
hashirama and after receiving his
father's powers he could use all five
basic transformations
as well as yananyang release as if a
giant wooden avatar wasn't enough
after he inherited his father's powers
he gained access to six paths and jutsu
and
an orange kurama-looking chakra avatar
with three faces and six arms
known as kunitsukami kunitsukami could
do battle with indra's full body susano
and asura even had truth-seeking orbs
that he could use in combination with it
clearly in the anime they added a lot of
features from hashirama and
naruto into the character of asura since
they were his reincarnations
asura also had a wife that was revealed
in the anime otsutsuki number five kana
otutuki
she lived in a village where asura was
helping out they met they fell in love
they married
obviously she married into the clan so
she won't be as op
as most members on this list however she
did excel in healing jutsu
and learned the mystical palm technique
where you apply your hand to the wounded
body part and send chakra into it
the technique accelerates the body's own
healing abilities but not everyone can
use it
since you need to be able to use just
enough chakra or you can do more harm
than good
now let's turn to hagaromo's younger
brother hamura aka otutuki number six
he is the ancestor of the hyuga clan and
was the leader of the shinobi on the
moon
as i mentioned he peaced out to the moon
where the husk of the ten tales was
sealed after he and hagoromo defeated
their mother kaguya even though hamura
was not as strong as hagoromo he was
still one of the strongest figures in
the naruto universe
like hagoromo he inherited his mother's
powerful chakra
and was even able to transcend death
itself even after death
hamura could appear before shinobi and
grant them his power
just like hagoromo did with naruto
hamura actually gave power to hinata
hyuga
his descendant so yeah boruto is pretty
much bound to be op
one parent is descended from hagoromo
and got chakra from him while the other
is descended from hamura and got chakra
from him within boruto is the perfect
opi osutsuki cocktail so i look forward
to seeing how this insane potential
continues to manifest itself hamura had
the biaku god
allowing him to have nearly 360 degree
x-ray vision and to see the chakra
pathway system he also appears to have
had the ten saigon
a special dojutsu or ipower that evolves
from the byakugan
although we don't see him with the
uniquely colored eyes it is suggested
that he had them in a naruto movie
and that he sealed their power in an
energy vessel also called the ten saigon
and it would be cool if he did have his
own evolved ojutsu
since hagoromo did get the shanigan
mangekyo sharingan and eventually the
rinnegan as well so it's only fair
anyways the 10 saigon energy vessel was
also fueled by the byakugan of
other ototsuki clan members on the moon
the power of the energy vessel could
animate puppets
letting them act as effective servants
it could also be used as a weapon
and the branch family of the otsuki clan
on the moon used it to beat the main
family that's how powerful it was
it can even send the moon crashing into
the earth only hamuda's chakra can
destroy it which is why hamuna's spirit
gives his chakra to hinata
so she can work together with naruto in
order to finally stop the op weapon and
although we don't see hamura use it
we do get to learn about its powers from
toneri otsutsuki
more on him later but some notable 10
saigon powers include the ability to
enter tensegon chakra mode and manifest
truth-seeking orbs to use attraction and
repulsion powers that are strong enough
to move the moon
itself and the ability to summon a golem
that can fight with kurama
and even the ability to create a chakra
sword that can straight up slice the
moon in half toneri is 10 saigon
fades after naruto punches him in the
face but we can assume that hamuras
would have been much less sensitive
so yeah all around a very powerful
dojutsu besides this hamura could
teleport to the moon and back freely he
was skilled enough in stealing jutsu to
help his brother defeat the all-powerful
kaguya and he was able to use six paths
and jutsu
just like hagoromo which allowed him to
fly as well he had true seeking orbs
also
all in all hamura is an interesting
figure that added a cool dimension
to the hyuga clan making them unique and
not just another offshoot of hagoromo
now since we already mentioned him let's
address toneri our seventh otsuki he was
the descendant and only survivor of the
otusuki clan on the moon he was
specifically from the branch family not
the main family another parallel with
the hugo clan
toneri was not on hamura's level and
couldn't just awaken to 10 saigon he
needed to first take the byakugan
of a huge clan member and then wait for
them to mature
into the tensega he took hinata's
sister's eyes and then wanted to marry
hinata
and when i was watching a movie the
whole time i was thinking that stealing
a girl's sister's eyes is probably not
the best way to win her over
but whatever toneri is clearly not the
most socially calibrated dude
among his notable achievements he could
for a time fight evenly with naruto
zumaki the strongest shinobi who helped
defeat kaguya herself
he was able to communicate with other
people from great distances
through their dreams or through
projections toneri could mind read
absorb chakra and spy on the happenings
on earth from the moon
he had an army of puppets at his
disposal that were animated by the power
of the 10 saigon energy vessel which was
also under tonnary's control toneri can
even turn people into puppets by placing
a sphere of chakra within them
although born with the biakugan his eyes
were sealed away in the energy vessel so
he had to use his sense rather than his
vision
until he transplanted hanabi hyuga's
eyes into himself
these eyes eventually matured into the
tenseagon which allowed him to access
the tenseigon chakra mode that allowed
him to compete against
naruto in this mode he had true seeking
orbs could deplete chakra
could earthbend the moon and launch
chunks of it at naruto
could use attraction and repulsion to
control something as big as the moon
could use a huge chakra sword to cut the
moon in two and could form a golem
strong enough to keep
kurama busy he was definitely strong but
easy to defeat since the 10 saigon
faded away after one satisfying punch to
the face from naruto and you gotta
expect a punch to the face if you tried
to steal hinata from naruto
as toneri did we also briefly saw
osutsuki number eight in the movie as
well he was the unnamed head to the main
family on the moon
as usual his biakugan was taken at birth
and put into the 10 sega
he was killed when the branch family
used that very tense saigon
against him and the rest of the main
family we don't know much about his
powers but he was able to share his past
with hinata
showing that he was another who could
appear and help even after his physical
death otsutsuki number nine
is none other than the current villain
in the boruto manga ishiki
ishiki as we discover was actually the
partner of kaguya but was betrayed by
her
he was on the verge of death but
encountered a monk named jigen
and survived by shrinking himself so
that he could enter the monk's body
and absorb his nutrients his power is
insane
in a weaker form still in jegan's body
and not fully reincarnated jigen was
able to defeat the combined forces of
naruto and sasuke although his imperfect
vessel
did reach its limit in the process
according to a motto
ishiki with his full power would be able
to destroy the earth itself
and no one would be able to stop him as
we learn ishiki
and other ototsuki clan members use the
ability comma or
karma depending on the translation you
use karma lets the otsutuki
create a backup of themselves in a host
and then the karma matures
until the otsutuki is fully reincarnated
in their body
of course it's not that simple it can't
just be any body
if the body is imperfect it won't be
able to take the power of the otozuki
and the otozuki will die unless they
find a better vessel
for this reason amado along with kashin
koji
helped to get ishiki to reincarnate in
jigen's dead body
instead of kawaki's now ishiki is
stronger than before the reincarnation
but he only has a few days before
the body falls apart in that time he
hopes to impart another karma onto
kawaki
which would supposedly lead to a perfect
vessel in which case he would be in
theory unstoppable ishiki was durable
af and could take kicks from naruto in
six path sage mode
and be fine tonari couldn't even take a
punch so that shows that even among the
otusuki
ishiki is on a whole other level ishiki
can fly which makes sense for an osutuki
he can absorb chakra as well so that
even the highest level of fire release
amaterasu has no effect on him ishiki
has also fought with black rods that can
drain chakra from the punctured enemy
he can use space-time ninjutsu to travel
across vast distances
and even dimensions and he was skilled
enough to seal naruto away
he called out sasuke susano for being
slow and broke through its armor to get
to sasuke like it was nothing
with ishiki's right eye he is able to
use tsukuna hikona which allows him to
shrink himself in any non-living thing
around him and to restore them back to
normal size
once he shrinks things he can use
daikokuten
to store them in another dimension in
which time doesn't flow
then with his gaze he can re-manifest
them at their normal size
in this way he could unexpectedly drop
massive objects on opponents
in a split second and cause massive
damage he even used this ability with a
glass of wine which was classy af
he also uses this ability in conjunction
with his chakra absorbing black rods
overall as you can see ishiki is an
absolute beast and i can't wait to see
how they end up stopping him in boruto
ototoki number 10 is momoshiki
another chakra hungry otozuki who was
investigating what happened to kaguya
and ended up being defeated by a father
son rasengan from boruto
but momoshiki did manage to place his
karma on the boy
in the anime momoshiki claims that he
could have defeated kaguya
after absorbing kinshiki osutsuki who
will get into it a bit he was pretty
much able to flex on the kage
as he had naruto and friends trapped in
place with the shadow paralysis
technique
it was borto came to rescue with his
vanishing lasenga if not for boruto
momoshiki would have likely taken home
the w
albeit kataske was partially to blame
for that
because his attack was absorbed by
momoshiki and thus restored his
exhausted power
even after being killed momoshiki's
spirit or chakra could appear before
boruto
for whom it seemed like time stopped at
this point he left him with his
karma and apparently saw boruto's fate
with his biakugan
obviously his byakugan could also do the
usual near 360 degree x-ray vision stuff
and see the chakra pathway system
momoshiki also had a pair of rinnegan
in the palms of his hands his right
could absorb any chakra based technique
through his left he could release that
absorbed technique but with magnified
power
then he could turn people into pills
that he could consume for continued
longevity he would gain not only their
chakra but their techniques as well like
other naruto characters we've seen
momoshiki uses black receiver rods to
fight they can be fired at opponents in
order to restrain them or even kill them
momoshiki could also use space-time
ninjutsu to travel across dimensions
but it would take a lot of chakra
instead of truth seeking orbs
momoshiki used the tool creation
technique which let him create weapons
and telepathically control them with the
renegade he can use all five nature
transformations including especially
powerful fire
release and wind release techniques and
could even create a golem that was
beating kurama
until sasuke surrounded it with susano
in the novel he was capable of using
wood release as well
just like asura in the first hokage
currently his karma power means
that he's slowly taking over boruto
until he gains complete control of his
body there have already been instances
where momoshiki took over boruto's body
like when he was fighting against boro
through borto's body momoshiki flew
called boro an
inferior creature since he has a god
complex absorb chakra from naruto
and finish boro off with an absolutely
massive dasengan
next to which bortol looked like an ant
for now momoshiki's karma has been a
cool kurama-esque power boost for boruto
but
the more time passes the greater the
danger that momoshiki will fully
resurrect
and boruto will be gone forever
furutuzuki number 11
we got kinshiki another member of the
ototouki main family and momoshiki's
foster father he was subservient to
momoshiki he consumed his guardian's
chakra
and was ready to let momoshiki consume
him kinshiki used the tool creation
technique in battle as well
he'd create glowing red weapons like a
giant axe
and wield them proficiently in battle he
could also launch them telepathically
he was another flyer and he excelled in
sensing chakra which allowed him to
locate the chakra of the tailed beasts
he could surround himself in purple
lightning to increase his power and
speed
and even sasuke seemed noticeably
surprised by said speed
probably in part because kinshiki is not
the skinniest guy around
kinshiki also possessed the biakugan
which are pretty standard issue for most
ottutsuki
he appeared to fight equally with sasuke
until the latter
saw momoshiki too and decided to escape
using space-time ninjutsu however sasuke
did cut off the tip of kinshiki's horn
which bothered kinshiki to no
end so although he was like momoshiki's
assistant he was strong and even
multiple kage failed to stop him
he peaced out on his terms being
absorbed by his foster son
otsuki number 12 is the anime only
urashiki another member of the main
family who tagged along with momoshiki
and kinshiki
on their trip to earth another guy who
could take on multiple kage
except this one used a fishing rod as a
weapon like most other otutsuki he could
fly
and survive in space he could absorb
most techniques believe it or not his
fishing rod could break through strong
defenses
and take chakra from an opponent that
chakra would be stored in his gourd and
he could then use the techniques of that
person
for instance with gara's chakra he could
create and manipulate sand and battle
other notable abilities include being
able to use space-time ninjutsu to
travel to other dimensions
being able to create and use black
receiver odds in battle
being able to control puppets without
chakra strings as well as being able to
use barrier ninjutsu for protection
copying powers is always a useful
ability to have and by the end of it
urashiki was able to use many kinds of
different powers
including lightning release wind release
fire release earth release he can
manipulate his shadow to trap opponents
and use genjutsu to control a person's
actions and more
like most otsutsuki he possessed a biaku
god
unlike most otsuki though he could
transform his eyes into the renagon
uniquely he was able to use different
powers by changing the rinnegan's color
red meant being able to warp through
space-time and dimensions
blue meant temporal rewind allowing him
to warp several seconds into the past
and his own personal version of the body
replacement technique didn't involve
logs or even crows like hitachi's by red
origami cranes despite his insane powers
and the transformation urashiki was
eventually defeated after traveling
through time by a father son rasengan
with some help from sasuke and jaraya
and given its power
and recurring usefulness i'd say the
father son of sengon
is a worthy successor to the father son
kamehameha from dragon ball
which it always makes me think of and
that is it for this truly long video
about the ottatsuki clan
among other powers we saw most of the op
genkai that we know of in this clan
including the shotgun
renagan biakugan tensaigon and even wood
release
despite constantly popping up as
villains the otsuki clan is actually the
predecessor
of all other ninja clans if not for
these aliens
we wouldn't have all of the cool
chakra-based powers and techniques that
we've come to know so well
ironically while wanting all chakra for
herself kaguya actually ended up
spreading the chakra and creating
fighters strong enough to stop her and
even other ototsuki anyways if you did
enjoy the video and to unlock the next
one
make sure to smash that like button turn
it blue and share this video with your
culture naruto friends when we hit 5 000
likes i'll get certain the next one asap
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell
and set it to all or you will end up
missing future naruto videos leave
suggestions for what video you want to
see next and i'll pick one from the
comment section below and while you wait
for that video to drop
feel free to check out my naruto
playlist where i got videos about the
hokage
uchiha uzumaki and more link in the
description a very special
thank you goes to our patrons over on
patreon who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans steven and grotta alola
nothing the world
steelers acquire respect pate hepa
jonathan king brandon of isles papa
smurf emperor otaku
thomas jones ken mano and admirath
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh who's the current
most donated overall champion
of the world nothing but a fan jason
wilson kings elders anatoly kazatsky
angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor
jessica kayla font hinokami and water
body parks rethuan de aura
deadly saint and stern hawkins thank you
all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
animepro and becoming a patron today for
as long as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to our private patron only
discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button
next to the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you